I was eight years old my mother died she
loved traveling the world and digging up
the past he used to visit all the time
no one day everything changed she had
found something something he wanted he
would have killed me too
[Applause]
it's changing
[Music]
nothing could stand in the face of this
I love to
before she died
your mother told me she was afraid of
Valentine and that if anything should
happen to her that was to find you that
you could stop him
she could be a problem if she's anything
like a mother what happens when you find
a stash or
we'll give
he's here
the great game of survival this is
checkmate
why didn't you leave me shut up in the
run you sure you want to do this I have
to go my mother
you look at her and all you see by the
jagged edges but she is something quite
different she is beautiful and strange
and very very rare hi sir take this and
sad aside until I give you the signal
what signal I'm not that subtle
[Music]
okay silly boys take it from here I
gotta go late for church
[Music]
Hey look after
[Music]
look at me are you murdered
so much
he was saying the guy sees things and
then she's miserable
she said you murdered her mother
misson ugly word
I'm sorry you idea that I should go yeah
[Music]
strange to think this is what it looked
like 21st century yep
it's so different well that's what
happens when the Earth's crust gets
shattered into a thousand pieces check
this out this is what I wanted to show
you it's a quantum energy weapon they
were dozens of them all over the globe
can a society so advanced so scientific
be so stupid almost you wasn't people
today that you said far worse weapons
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that was close
[Music]
what the hell is southies
[Music]
[Music]
white
[Music]
morning Jesus sit in a world that we
have never seen
[Music]
it's a wonderfully imagined world that
has been realized by Peter Jackson and
his team the breadth of vision that they
brought to Lord of the Rings they're
going to bring the same to mortal
engines the cities are actually moving
their traction cities are massive the
big cities in gist smaller towns in
London as one of the biggest they are on
a mission to hunt down another town
go mad at the heart of this story is
Hester
when we first he has to she's this
mysterious feral badass
histories on a mission to exact
vengeance and kill the person who
murdered her mother she'd like to live
in a world with us one less person in it
Valentine and that's Valentine this is
for my mother
there goes things don't go according to
plan engines is the story of two people
crashing into each other
asking what you murdered my mother
there's about characters in their
journey beyond the hand that fate has
dealt them
Tom and Hester aren't forced into a
situation where they have to rely on
each other to survive rather than it's
awesome that we have a character like
history Shaw who is so wild and so
driven as to Shaw she won't stop until
I'm gender there were so many moments of
pure joy working in such a fantastical
world your mother Jeff found something
dangerous we had the chance to write a
really great mystery
besides in the scope and the imagination
of this thing I'm gonna be as amazed by
this movie is the audience a man who
controls this choice the world not if we
shut it down it's about something bigger
than just her revenge sure you want to
do this I have to something I always
want to imagine I'm going to spin two
years producing our movie
let's go do something I have never seen
that
is London 60 minutes is all it took to
bring humanity to the very brink of
extinction mankind mobilized a new age
arose age the great predator city's
survival of the fastest
Hey Hotel Valentine this is for my
mother
stop
Oh ask him what you murdered my mother
I'm sorry you had to head
as to saw she won't stop until I'm dead
unless you kill her first
I want them found
I've been looking for you for a long
time
your mother she said she had found
something dangerous she was afraid of
Valentine of what he might do man
controls this controls the world she
said that you could stop him
this weapon from wipeout the largest
city in the blink of an eye
not if we shut it down
nothing can stand in the face of this we
have to stop London before it destroys
us you sure you want to do this once we
go in there's no going back I have to
[Applause]
these massive cities they are so
visually appealing from a movie point of
view the concept that big cities eat
small cities and as a result they
evolved London's a pyramid tiered
Society done the root base you have the
gut workers down in the great engine
rooms
then as you go up to you by TIA that
people get more and more wealthy my
character definitely belongs to the
upper decks the upper echelon of society
the traction cities are all about
survival of the fastest and it down and
then you have people that want to change
the world
London's heading east towards John Kuo
the anti traction week is a league of
warriors they're just defending our way
of life we have to stop London before it
destroys us they have very different
philosophies about how to survive those
that want to live in static settlements
have all shored up their resources and
all of the air and peace and harmony
tonight we take the fight to the ant
attraction League engines is the story
of all these worlds crashing into each
other the physics behind some of the
stuff that we're building
it's definitely finding that sweet spot
between something which is convincing
and selling that stale when it came to
ingesting out other cities that we all
don't agree figured that one out
we did have tests we didn't look at a
lot of reference especially big
machinery crumbling you're gonna
destroyed mortal engines fills like it's
got a great rolling momentum to it how
often do we go to the movies today and
see things that we genuinely have never
seen before when somebody sees somebody
wearing a costume for a movie a lot of
people don't take into account
everything that happens behind the
scenes all of the research and the
sourcing and the manufacturing and the
aging and finishing and all of that
comes together to what you see on camera
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's world class the people that we're
working with there's so much talent and
there's so much that can be showcased I
think we're pretty spoiled on mortal
engines because it's not just one look
I love my job in the sense that I get
the privilege of seeing these amazing
illustrations come to life we are
actually building on something that
isn't just a contemporary costume it's a
feast for the eyes I had a very creative
childhood
thanks to my grandmother I just
absolutely loved it most people see
Hester they will see that the valuation
of textures and fabrics and light but
for me it's an amazing puzzle I'm one of
those people that if you get given the
most crazy printed fabric and you've got
to pattern match it I love it
making flow then has run in the family
from my mother being a seamstress and my
grandparents were tailors I've really
enjoyed making costumes for histor I
think she's a really empowering woman to
say
anything can be created anyone can
design but to be a good costume designer
is to have a good understanding the
character people have to look like
they've lived in that question it is
them when you see he because have the
costume on the character starts coming
to life it's a beautiful process to
witness my name is Naomi Campbell I'm
the principal design coordinator my name
is Anna Deakin and I am the lead patent
drafter and cutter my name is Melissa
Mont and I am a costumer Sheamus on
mortal butcher
[Music]
what is that it's London
[Music]
[Music]